Oh my god!
My computer is...
Late!
My computer says it's 6...
56...
But my phone says 657!
It's 30 seconds behind!
Oh my god!
How does that happen on a computer?
How does it even happen?
They can sometimes get out of sync?
No way!
Anyway!
Welcome back, master and princess!
I don't have much time to talk before the debut begins.
Welcome!
Today we'll be watching Daisy Dandelion from Idol EN's debut!
It's actually, I think, my first ever sponsored stream.
So...
Yippee!
Yay!
So... Yay!
I've been asked before for other watch-alongs, but...
I was always busy.
Or planning other stuff or whatever, so...
But...
You know, I thought maybe I would try it.
And it's fun to watch debuts, so...
You know, it's not like I never watched the other ones before.
But it's also more fun to watch with a crowd of people, so...
Yeah.
But...
Yeah!
So...
Cool!
I'll stop the music, obviously, once it starts.
It'll start in two minutes.
I had a bit of a... I'm tired today.
I'm tired today.
I had to go...
Visit...
My family.
So I'm tired.
But yeah.
I don't know what to say.
I feel like I'm gonna be awkward.
I'm gonna be like...
Cute!
And one thing I'm most...
Rather, one thing I like seeing the most about debuts is...
Zalink you pinned okay.
Yep, it's all good.
Yep.
No worries.
But...
One thing I'm most excited to see about...
About...
Vtubers from their debuts is like what their anime likes are, you know?
So...
I guess we'll see that.
And of course, there's the links.
If you are interested in watching.
Or if you're here, you should watch!
So...
It should be beginning.
I'm gonna turn off the music just preemptively so that...
When it starts...
I'm gonna...
It'll not start with the music.
Bets on who's gonna be the MGS fan.
I'm telling...
I look for it.
Literally every single...
Every single...
Debut I've ever watched.
I was just like, I wonder...
Oh!
It's starting!
I've always looked to see if they like Metal Gear.
Oh, the intro is so cute!
I wonder if the stuff on the TV will change.
Let's see, what do they like?
What's some stuff in here that...
I see Tamagotchi.
Oh!
I think...
We can hear...
Oh!
The Ian scuff.
That was a Love Live reference.
Actually, on...
On...
On Twitter earlier, she said...
So maybe she knows idol stuff.
We'll see.
Moogle in the cabinet?
Oh!
I see it!
Yeah, there's a Moogle.
We got a Gamecube.
And we have...
What is that?
A Famicom?
So we have maybe a Boomer?
Maybe we have a Boomer?
Stop!
No!
Thank you for the pink.
No, thank you.
A DS?
Where?
Oh, I see a Wii.
I don't see the...
Oh, I see a Switch.
Oh no, she's a gamer?
I see a...
PSP?
Oh, I see...
I think it's a PSP next to the...
Next to the DS.
This is such a cute...
Such a cute intro.
She's so yellow.
A hag for sure.
Let's go.
No respect for the GBA?
Where?
Or is that the PSP?
Is it a PSP or...
I don't even see it.
There's so much stuff.
Is it Game Boy Advance?
Not a PSP?
Looks like a PSP to me.
The PSP is a GBA.
They have similar looks.
I think it's a PSP, you guys.
It has the buttons.
It has the little left and right trigger.
I think it's a PSP.
I don't think it's color accurate.
A GBA had those?
I didn't have one.
I didn't have a GBA.
Talking about the one on the bed or the cabinet?
The one on the cabinet.
The one on the bed is definitely a Game Boy.
Oh, I didn't even notice that.
We're like psychoanalyzing this room.
We're like...
What do you got in there, Daisy?
What do you got in there?
It's a little boomer.
That's OK though.
We welcome hags here.
Right?
Oh.
She's a lion, right?
Oh my goodness.
Oh no, it's the...
It's the Teletubbies baby, but it's a cat?
Oh my god.
Teletubbies.
We're going into the sun.
It's Outer Wilds.
This is so cute.
Oh my gosh, wait, they're little Teletubbies.
Oh
no, I think they're getting a little crazy.
Crazy.
Oh!
Idle Girl Advance.
It is a Game Boy.
You guys are right.
You guys were right.
I was wrong.
I admit defeat.
RIP to the PSP.
Who had a PSP anyway?
What's up with the shell?
Cute!
PSP was great.
It's nobody had the Vita.
Daisies in the trap, baby!
She's pollinating us, you guys.
Gotta
grow a daisy!
I got a package, alright.
Grow a daisy.
Oh my gosh, we're burying her alive.
She's a hungry flower.
What's this accent?
Water?
The chat!
Oh there it is!
There's the water!
Oh!
Oh my God.
Metal Gear.
Oh
my God.
She's evolving.
Insane in the membrane.
Don't go in the chat and say Metal Gear.
I see you guys.
Where is the Metal Gear?
Because...
The exclamation point.
Oh!
What is happening?
Oh she's growing!
I was like what is happening?
What is happening?
Oh she can't stop growing.
A giantess VTuber maybe.
Oh my gosh, even the Katamari music.
The gentle people.
Oh,
what is that?
Is that the mascot?
Is that her mascot character?
Popeye laugh.
Oh the glasses!
So cute!
Oh it fits her so well.
I can't tell if that's part of her stream or if it's buffering a little.
Her butt.
The butthole!
No, don't get the pants!
It's so cute.
I love X buttholes.
So she's a plant and a lion?
Does she eat water or meat?
What about the water in the meat?
X butt.
Yeah!
The X butthole.
Oh, what's going on?
What
are foot fumes?
We love a criminal.
Oh my gosh, wait, I just noticed she has the Koharu like...
Striped down her middle.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, we're already going to her place.
The first and the last.
Last time.
This animator.
Wait, what's wrong?
Wait, what happened?
I'm confused.
Why did she stop the lore video?
What was wrong with it?
I'm confused.
We don't need to see the rest.
Oh, mangaka.
She must not like lore.
I guess so.
The lore.
It's so important.
It's what makes a VTuber.
What?
Oh this...
Oh sexy!
What did the lion do?
The certificate...
Certificate...
Of awesome.
Maskos.
The lion is king of the jungle.
No!
Stole my certificate?
I never had a certificate of awesome.
Maybe I should work for that.
Maybe I should go back to school for a certificate of awesome.
I like her art so much.
It's so cute.
It's so silly.
Oops!
Clap everybody!
We clap!
Yeah, there you go guys.
Good job, good job.
The wares.
There is the certificate.
So cute!
OK, now we can see what stuff she is into.
She is not a liar.
She is a lion.
That Hamtaro game.
It's the only game one of my friends has ever played, ever.
Literally just that Hamtaro game.
That is the only game she has ever played.
Picross!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, Picross 3D though.
Energy.
The background is so cute.
Oh my gosh.
Toys.
30M.
So true.
Internet safety everybody.
30 million.
She is mighty young.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm going to start.
Wait, I can say that too.
I'm forever 19...wait.
Forever...why did I just say I'm forever 19?
I mean it's true.
Forever 90?
No!
I never said...I said 19!
Forever 19.
Oh cute!
A dandelion.
I want
to see the...does it like shake?
The little...the Etch-a-Sketch?
Does it...I just want to shake it and make...like start drawing on it, you know?
Hello?
Forever 9 team.
What do you mean 9?
Who do you mean team?
It's so cute!
Oh my gosh, what a fun interface!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, no.
Cute!
Oh my gosh, it's so cute!
It's so cute!
And the sound effects and everything.
Oh my gosh.
Orange cat.
Standing cat is actually...
She loves growing until it's too much.
Cute!
Daisy OS.
Oh no!
The virus!
Yes, I do!
Yes, I do.
Yes.
It can only pick one thing.
Oh my gosh, cute!
Oh my gosh, so cute!
She put so much effort into this, wow.
Daisy...the live...oh wow!
Yeah, I need my grandma glasses on.
Guys?
Wait, is it actually working?
Oh my gosh.
It reminds me...oh my gosh.
Cute!
King of the hill.
Real MySpace vibes.
It's like...the site is like pre-Tumblr, I feel.
It's so cute!
There's more!
Wait, what is this?
Oh my gosh, Minecraft B.
What's so cute?
Wait, what is this?
What is Rubes XYZ?
I've never heard of this before.
There's a guestbook!
Oh my gosh, so cute!
That's so cool.
Oh my gosh.
She prepared so much, for real.
Snoopy!
Oh my gosh, I love Snoopy.
They're whispering.
I can't understand their language.
Fandy Lion?
Oh my gosh, that was so cute.
I love it.
Oh.
Wait a second.
Guys?
I recognize...guys?
Dismute?
No way.
You guys, no way, it's the music.
You guys, no way!
No way.
No way, it's my music.
It's my music.
I say it's the music I used before.
No way!
I'll take the nugs.
Let's go!
These look legit, I think.
These are legit.
Who
is bootlegging the Iron Giant?
No!
It's too sad.
Don't bootleg the Iron Giant.
No!
At least pay for that one.
Wait, what's the code?
Cute!
I'm hungry.
The fancy stuff.
The good stuff.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, it makes sense.
There is no scuff here.
Stop!
No, I'm not yucking it.
I'm yumming it.
Oh my gosh, this stuff was my favorite ever!
I used to eat the Kids Cuisine so much!
Oh my gosh.
I always loved the mac and cheese because it was just basically flavorless.
And then the brownie was like perfection.
Oh my gosh!
Everything in the box tasted the same.
It was so good though!
The worst was when the corn ended up in the brownie and it was just like a little soggy.
It made the brownie soggy.
It was kind of gross.
No, it was so good though.
Oh, we're dancing?
We're dancing?
We're dancing while we wait for...
our food to be done.
TV dinner.
Oh, we're dancing too?
What?
No, wait.
You put it in with the box.
Okay.
Cute!
This is hot.
Wait, where did the brownie go?
Oh wait, no.
The brownie was not my favorite.
It was the pudding!
It was the pudding that was my favorite.
But I never had mashed potatoes.
The pudding was so good!
It wasn't the brownie.
It was the pudding.
What is in there?
Sasuga flower.
Cute!
It's true.
Yeah.
No, the pudding one is the... The pudding one, especially when it gets that little...
It gets that like film on top of it.
In her what?
Everything in her what?
In her lions.
Okay, okay.
A what?
It's okay.
I don't know anything about beer either.
The number one.
It's a big deal.
It's a big deal guys.
Herb?
Her?
Here?
Herb?
Which is it?
She hates you?
No!
Herbivore?
Wait, herbicide?
Herbicide!
Oh no Herbicide!
No!
Aren't daisies not...Dandelions aren't weeds either, right?
Technically, but I guess some people call them weeds.
Let's go to war against the herbicide.
What?
Herbicide?
Herbicide.
Which is it?
Dandelions are weeds?
They are.
Bluey?
Wait, is Bluey actually that good?
Futurama?
What was the cat?
Oh, the chi of the cat.
Silly!
Blue ads!
Wait, this is...my whole stream right now is an ad.
Oh that was Powerpuff Girls, I think.
What?
Beavis and Byhen?
Bluey...Lion Girl!
This face!
A
freak?
What's wrong with being a freak?
Oh cute!
What is this?
This picture?
Oh no.
It's her as a baby.
It's so cute!
You guys, I think it looks like her.
Oh my God, the eye color is even the same.
The eye color is even the same.
Oh...
She is so cute!
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
I don't want to touch the grass though.
No!
Wait, I thought that was the herbicide coming in for the total herbicide war.
What's the middle one?
Oh my gosh, so cute.
What is...Oh I just noticed the lace on her neck.
Oh my gosh, so pretty.
Oh my gosh, so cute!
Yeah, Ralph is really cute.
Stop!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, stop!
The Teheran is so cute!
Oh...
I want to see her full outfit.
I love her hair too.
Oh my gosh, the head.
The chibi mode is so cute.
Who is doing that?
Who is grabbing the stop grow?
What's something cool?
Oh my gosh, a magic trick.
A magic trick.
Why?
Why are we in the sky?
What's happening?
Wait, actually?
What is happening?
Wait, is it...
Yeah.
Oh, ok, just kidding.
Ok, it's live baby!
It's live baby!
I'm ready.
I thought he was going to come out of nowhere.
You got this!
You got this Daisy!
Daisy!
I
want one too.
Oh my gosh.
The stylophone.
I'm into collecting weird instruments.
What's bread?
Oh,
how many rooms does she have?
Oh my gosh, we are being teleported to a different place every...
This is a big house.
We'll be raiding her next, so...
Cute.
A tree for us!
Oh?
A phandelion.
Oh my gosh, a christening.
Oh, cute!
Oh my gosh, so cute!
So cute!
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
it's also early.
3PM EST.
Let's see.
Oh my
gosh, so cute!
So Circe will be raiding... Oh gosh.
I guess we'll be raiding right into her...
I think it started already, so...
Thank you guys for watching the debut with me!
We'll be raiding into Circe.
I know she's a ghost, but always remember who your number one ghost is.
Well, maybe she'll be your number one ghost pirate, but I'm your number one ghost maid.
OK!
Thank you guys for watching with me!
See you guys later!
Bye bye!